Sam is with us in Grand Junction hi Sam
how are you I'm good how are you sir
better than I deserve how can I help so
right now I just completed baby step one
I just recently discovered you I had
some friends that I went through in
college and I just graduated and right
now I have 80,000 in student loans I'm a
mechanical engineer and I'm on the job
hunt but primarily why I'm calling
because I know that you like a little
bit about your story and I was wondering
what it took for you to make sure you
didn't like do like a done spending
mistake or things like that when you
know you're basically just going full
force to the debt there's just some days
I'm like I want to feel this bad I want
to get it done
and then other days it's like I really
want to go spend this on XYZ stupid item
and so I was wondering how you built
maintain the discipline to keep on track
towards being debt-free
well I have the benefit of being married
to a lady who is not impressed with me
and so she calls out my stupidity for
the last 36 years pretty regularly
that's one thing accountability in other
words I'm joking around but
accountability helped it sometimes you
can use a friend for that or a parent
for that a pastor for that a spouse for
that whatever but someone that says hey
I'm gonna walk with you and I'm gonna
get up in your business if you start
messing up okay the second thing is that
I had a huge and always recommend this
to others as well a huge reason I've a
huge why if you have a hawai that is big
enough it will draw you away from being
sloppy in your discipline to give you an
example of that if the doctor came in
and said if you don't lose 10 pounds in
the next two months you're going to die
100% chance you die if you don't lose 10
pounds
guess what you're gonna do you ever now
have a really big why you are gonna lose
10 pounds there is no cookie in the
world that looks that good right but if
it's kind of like I think I'm I feel
better and the jeans might fit better if
I lost a little weight the cookies look
better than that right and so you got to
have a big why on whatever it is you're
doing and the bigger your y the more
discipline the more intense the more
focused you'll get there them you know
and the more urgency you'll have with it
and so what I would do is and it can be
a positive thing a negative thing it
doesn't have to be you're gonna die it
can just be that you know that I really
I can visualize see myself being wealthy
and I can see the amount of generosity I
could do if I was wealthy and it breaks
my heart to look at this certain group
of people that are hurting and I could
help that group of people God could use
me to do that and so I'm going to pay a
price to win just to be able to do that
that's a positive why right it doesn't
have to be I'm gonna die right it can
don't have to be that it can just be you
know I've got real big things to do with
money and so I need to go get some and
you need to outline that Chris Hogan
says to make sure that in his book
retire inspired he says make sure your
dreams your why is in high definition HD
it's like your HDTV remember the old TVs
wonder what an HD if you happen channels
although they changed their cable line
up in Nashville our channels on where
they are on accidentally landed on some
of the old channels they still got them
going out that aren't HD and I'm like I
can't watch football on that it's just
it's awful I don't know how we I don't
know how we did it back in the Stone Age
before we had HD then so I mean you got
out of HD I mean come on this is a 4G
maybe right I mean three def you know
hologram you know what is it I mean but
but you just get your dreams really
crystal clear smell the waves breaking
smell the salt off the salt water as the
waves are breaking on the sand
if you're gonna do a vacation trip in
the Caribbean are you going to own a
house there in the Caribbean and you
want to live you want be able to go down
there and visit right let's just have to
set that aside I mean you got a it's got
to be you got to hear it you got to
smell it you got to feel it the Sun on
your face you got to think about what
it's going to be like to be out there
fishing as the sun's coming up if you're
a fisherman because you were able to get
that bass boat because you got your
finances under control and you've got
the time to go do that whatever it is
you want to do I don't know but but you
got it needs to be crystal-clear HD your
goal your dream and that becomes your
why and then have folks come around you
and publicly state what your goal is
don't keep your goal keep your dream to
yourself say it out loud so that other
people even some of your friends might
shame you you know they might might be
negative accountability but dude I'm
doing this and then that what happened
to your deal you know that's coming at
you if you've said it publicly but if
you've not told anybody then that's the
other thing it's a really good question